para empezar pues las mujeres son la
mayoría del electorado en Brasil y
también la mayoría de la ciudadanía en
Brasil para estas elecciones son cerca
del 53% los votos femeninos y ahí han
encontrado los candidatos pues son
importantísimo capital de político vamos
a poner el ejemplo de Sao Paulo que es
donde nos encontramos el estado de Sao
Paulo reúne aproximadamente el 22% del
padrón electoral y aquí son 18 millones
de mujeres y 16 millones de hombres
entonces Usted ya puede hacer cuentas es
de la importancia de este voto femenino
y lo veníamos diciendo desde esta mañana
en los reportes el voto de la mujer
afrodescendientes particularmente
importante en esta ocasión especialmente
la mujer desde la periferia la mujer
empobrecida porque es el sector
poblacional que más ha sufrido los
efectos del empobrecimiento causado por
la pandemia y bajo la administración de
Jair bolsonaro y en ese sentido Pues hay
dos figuras que han sido adalids de cada
campaña por un lado pues está da si que
es digamos el cerebro de toda la campaña
de Lula y esta cara joven que ha traído
nuevas ideas al PT y por otro lado pues
está Michelle Revolucionario que se
autodenomina como una sierva de Dios y
que pide votos En nombre del capitán
como se le recuerda a bolsonaro por su
época militar Así que estas dos mujeres
podrían ser un ejemplo de de las
diversidades de opiniones que también se
concentran dentro de las mujeres y Pues
dentro de los indecisos